you may remember Who Framed Roger Rabbit
as a beloved animated film from your
childhood but if you watch it as an
adult you might be shocked at its
explicit content so I took a couple of
30 pitches so kill me I already got a
stiff on my hands thank you from the
movies colorful language to its varied
pop-culture references to the bodacious
Jessica Rabbit
here are some fascinating things about
Who Framed Roger Rabbit you only notice
as an adult pervy Herman if kids we may
have known something wasn't right about
a cartoon baby smoking a giant cigar but
the sexual predilections of baby Herman
may have gone over our innocent little
heads my problem is I get a
fifty-year-old lust and a three-year-old
dinky
baby Herman might look sweet but that's
just a party plays in the movies Herman
is a total perv when we first meet him
he takes a peek up a crew members skirt
and when Herman goes to see Eddie Herman
slaps his ladyfriend on the butt not
exactly the kind of things you'd want
kids to emulate pattycake when Eddie
captures Jessica Rabbit and Marvin Acme
playin pattycake in her dressing room
he thinks he struck gold to convince
Roger that his wife is cheating on him
[Music]
later the pictures show that Jessica and
Marvin really were playin pattycake but
judging by Rogers reaction they may as
well been playing Barry the carrot
instead whether or not pattycake is the
toon equivalent of sex if you were under
the age of 12 when you saw this movie
hopefully the entire bid would have been
lost on you bad rabbit as Jessica Rabbit
says I'm not bad I'm just drawn that way
and in one case that's definitely true
on the original laserdisc version when
Jessica and Eddie are in a high-speed
chase and thrown from the taxi there's a
moment where her dress reveals a little
more than you'd expect in a kids movie
but of course nothing about Jessica
Rabbit is exactly family-friendly nice
movie true alcoholic Eddie Eddie valiant
spends much of the movie in Dolores his
bar and when he's not there he's back in
his office drowning his sorrows Eddie's
brother who was also his partner was
killed by a toon and it's obvious that
Eddie of self-medicating his pain with
the help of booze watching the movie is
an adult it's obvious that Eddie is a
full-blown alcoholic but the movie at
least tries to warn its younger audience
members about the dangers of alcohol
when Roger is given a drink after
discovering Jeff
infidelity the results are pretty messy
probate problems in the Fein where
Eddie's trying to get his handcuffs off
Eddie suggests that Dolores go downtown
to check the probate on acnes will a
word Roger clearly misinterprets
something had a problem with his probate
he had a Pisces big down and to make
lots of water chances are you had no
idea what a prostate was when you were a
kid apparently neither does Roger in
human Doom the infamous shoe melting
scene in Who Framed Roger Rabbit is one
of the most traumatic cinematic moments
of our childhood thanks to Christopher
Lloyd's terrifying performance judge
doom goes down in the history books is
one of the scariest movie villains ever
it's hard to spot through his glasses
and he has some animated help at the end
of the movie but hardcore fans of the
film may have noticed that Lloyd does
something inhuman in every scene he
appears in he never blinks terrifying
invisible Harvey when judge doom storms
the bar looking for Roger one of the
patrons seems like he's about to give up
Rogers hiding spot and then he does this
hello it's a pretty random joke unless
you get the reference the man at the bar
was referring to Harvey a 1950 comedy
about an invisible rabbit starring Jimmy
Stewart and it just so happens that the
main character is an alcoholic like
Eddie who spends most of his time in a
bar singing sword looking for a weapon
in the final showdown with judge doom
Eddie grabs a prop out of a box in the
warehouse the singing sword
no it's strictly trouble
we're older viewers probably recognize
the sword is none other than Frank
Sinatra but that's not the only
pop-culture reference packed into this
short bit at the end of the film Eddie's
last name valiant is a reference to the
Prince Valiant comic strip of the late
1930s and 40s in it Prince Valiants
weapon of choice is you guessed it a
singing sword and drawn racism Who
Framed Roger Rabbit is packed with adult
themes one of the biggest of which is
its depiction of racism in Hollywood
cartoons are definitely being treated as
second-class citizens especially under
the reign of Judge doom who is overtly
racist against animated figures in the
movie the toons work as performers and
waiters at the club where Jessica sings
but the only patrons are humans in the
end Roger rabbit's achievements and
animation are only bolstered by this
extended metaphor on racism and
segregation
it's fascinating to rewatch the movie as
an adult while keeping this metaphor in
mind the best party they would be not
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our youtube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you'll love to
[Music]